The first known boat to
actually navigate underwater was,
of course, built by a Dutch dude.
The Dutch, man.
They're just so good at water.
150 years later, over here,
in what was soon to be the United States,
George Washington paid
for this sucker to be made for his army.
The Turtle,
because it kind of looked like two turtle
shells put together. So cute.
The guy in there is just like so cozy.
They tried to use “the turtle” in their war
for freedom against the British,
but it never really did anything useful.
And then it just sank
cool name
but wasn't a super useful submarine
but it paved the way.
50 years later,
we have the American Civil War,
where the Confederate rebels built a sub
that was powered by a bunch of guys
manually turning a crank and on board
it had a long spar torpedo.
Don’t be fooled, though
“spar torpedo” is just a fancy way
of saying a bomb on a 15 foot stick.
And they actually used it.
They snuck up on a Yankee ship
with their bomb stick
in the middle of the Civil War
and blew it up.
And both sides sank.
Like, the submarine sank too.
Like, it didn't work.
I mean, it kind of worked, but it–
didn't really work.